hi I'm grace Helbig I have both a
television show and a sense of style yes
my new show Andy and grace Helbig show
premieres this Friday April 3rd at 10:30
p.m. following the soup and I'm sure
you're very tired of hearing me say that
you
when you have a television show you come
up with a lot of different segment ideas
or funny bits or creative games and
things that you could do in the show to
make it interesting because watching a
human breathe without doing anything
isn't that compelling look just prove
myself wrong because that was god damn
moving yeah you moved on to a new video
didn't you and the reality is a lot of
the things that you come up with don't
make it to the show because they're
awful ly underappreciated so today I'm
gonna share with you my bit that bit it
all the pieces I came up with for the
show that are getting listed no one
loves it only listed let's do it I wrote
them down that's how you know they're
real
like wishes this bits called Alexander
scars can you guard I sit down with the
French Bulldog named Alexander and
collectively we decide how many
emotional scars Alexander Skarsgard can
guard or handle on a daily basis I mean
I go Seyfried I sit down with him into
Seyfried and blindfold her and feed her
food and she has to say fried if she
thinks it's fried food Grantley
correction a French Bulldog named
Alexander and I sit down and change one
word in one tweet from one member of One
Direction to make it an entirely
different tweet Alexander is great at it
please correct bunt my guests and I go
to a local ma and bunt eggs into a line
of people waiting to get photos taken
with a giant rabbit stuck in a pickle
one of my producers hides a prize inside
of a pickle in a bigger jar full of
other non prize hidden pickles I guess
and I eat pickles until one of us finds
the prize and is proclaimed princess or
Prince pickle of that episode I was
wonderful I don't know why I got next
crisscross applesauce
I eat applesauce with the members of
criss cross I was told it was too
political Taylor Swift Taylor Swift and
I have to mend clothing very quickly now
growling breathes on the camera lens up
close it's exactly like how it sounds I
challenge you to abdul kareem
abdul-jabbar and Paula Abdul
fight to the death very weasel my guest
has to guess whether they're drinking
vino wine or diesel gasoline couldn't
get a gas sponsor what a sad world we
live in America quickly lock with the
kardashians the kardashians and I have a
very civil sincere conversation about
which of us gets to keep our only copy
of the movie up when we're styling
Tori Spelling competes in a one-woman
Spelling Bee no edit Tori Spelling
competes in the Spelling Bee against a
bee
ooh could be great that's harm my knee
the members of fifth harmony get an
opportunity to kick me in a kneecap
biography I asked my guests which
celebrity they let pee on them really
great bit baileywick tumbler batch
I shall benedict cumberbatch all that
nasty fanfic you guys ran on tumblr
about him well there's all the bits I've
written so far that bit it didn't make
the cut so make sure you watch the very
first episode of the grace Helbig show
this Friday at 10:30 on a following the
soup to see which bits made it these are
all solid gold what could possibly be in
the show tune in to find out promotional
jargon promotional jurgen promotional
jargon i don't know what you're going
I'll find someone like you I take a
single girl on a hunt to find
oh man named Juan who would make a great
partner I'm just an endless stream of
hits